hey guys it's max today we're gonna be
taking a look at Samsung's new galaxy
book s now we first covered this back in
September when it was supposed to launch
shortly after he made that video but
Samsung held it back and waited more
than six months to release this new
laptop and today we're not only going to
take a look at it and look at its pros
and cons but also compare it to the new
13-inch MacBook Air since we have two
ultra books here then supposed to have
great battery life and decent
performance so let's start out by
opening up this very slim box here and I
will say I'm very excited for this
product not only because it's so slim
and white and it should be good quality
but because it doesn't use a regular
intel or AMD processor it's actually
using a Snapdragon processor basically
it was something that you'd find in an
Andhra just slightly tweaked now first
impressions in my hand it does feel nice
the edges are a little bit maybe sharper
than the MacBook Air but it feels very
similar other than a being just kind of
a little bit more lightweight I guess
this comes in at about 2.1 2.2 pounds or
so
compared to 2.7 5 and let's stack these
on top of each other here and they are
very close in size the Samsung is just
slightly longer whereas the MacBook Air
is slightly taller I guess and that but
that's why because it has a 16 by 10
display which we'll cover in just a bit
now let's take a look at the sides here
we have a USB type-c port and a
headphone jack over here thankfully they
didn't remove it on this and on the
other side we have another USB type-c
port now as far as thickness on the slim
side they are almost identical and then
on the thicker end it looks like they're
very close as well but that is because
the feet on the galaxy book S stick out
more and then when you're holding him in
your hand you could definitely tell that
the galaxy book s is slimmer and of
course you could tell that weight
difference as well now there's one extra
thing with the exterior of the galaxy
book s and that is this little cover
which hides a SIM card because with this
laptop you can actually pop in a SIM and
use data anywhere without needing to
have Wi-Fi and that is something that
you cannot get with a MacBook Air or a
MacBook Pro and along with that it can
also accept a microSD card now another
thing that the Snapdragon processor gets
you with the galaxy book is great
battery life samsung initially said this
would come out with 22 hours of video
playback and now with the release they
optimize it for up to 25 hours whereas
the MacBook Air is reading at 13 now as
far as actual battery capacities we have
about 50 watt hours with the MacBook Air
and 42 watt hours with the galaxy book
so the galaxy books battery is a little
bit smaller and as far as the chargers
they are including the same charger that
comes with their flagship smartphones
it's a 25 watt us pc charger whereas
with the MacBook Air we have a 30 watts
and I think because the batteries
smaller at the galaxy book it will
probably charge about the same speed the
Samsung has a nice large hand cutout and
to test the one-handed opening it is not
working so the hinge is a little bit too
stiff my opinion but that's probably on
purpose because it does have a
touchscreen and as far as keyboards the
MacBook Air has a third-generation
Butterfly keyboard which doesn't have
that much complaints compared to the
previous ones it does have very little
key travel but it does have a nice
clicky tactile feedback which helps out
but of course I love that new 16 inch
keyboard now with the surface book s we
also have nice large keys there more
squared off here and we do have a little
bit more key travel with the keys not by
much but it actually sits a little flush
to the chassis of the laptop and it's a
little bit more mushy so it's hard to
give a win to one or the other I guess
if I really had to choose I would choose
the MacBooks keyboard but they are
fairly similar now both these also have
touch ID or fingerprint sensors built
into their power buttons on the Makka
pakka near here and basically in the
same spot for the surface laptop 3 and
the last thing I want to cover as far as
the exterior of these devices is the
build quality the Galaxy book s is built
pretty well it doesn't feel cheap by any
means but it is built mainly out of
plastic compared to the MacBook Air that
has an all-aluminum chassis so it
definitely feels higher quality now
let's jump into comparing the displays
both these are
thirteen point three inches but you guys
can obviously see a difference
the MacBook Airs display looks much
larger and that's because it's a sixteen
by ten display meaning we have a little
bit more height compared to the galaxy
book s's and this gives us better
usability when you're surfing the web
you see more on screen at the same time
and if you're doing other productivity
tasks you're just gonna have a better
experience with a sixteen by ten display
now as far as quality we definitely have
some differences the galaxy buck-ass is
using a 1080p display and it is not IPS
are using a different technology whereas
the MacBook is using an IPS display and
it's a 2.5 or 2.6 K display so we
basically have about an extra 500
thousand pixels and to the eye from
normal distances if you're used to one
of these Retina displays you do notice a
little bit of the detail difference but
it's not that big of a difference
because this is a 13-inch display not a
15-inch now Samsung hasn't quoted any
spec as far as the display color
accuracy but playing back some
high-quality YouTube videos here I'm
getting a little bit more saturation
from the MacBook Airs display and also
more contrast as well and another thing
I'm noticing is we're getting a lot less
reflections with the MacBook Air
compared to the galaxy book s and I know
that MacBook Airs display is about a
hundred percent srgb rating so I think
in the full review of the galaxy book
asks I'm gonna have to do some testing
and I'll let you guys know so make sure
you guys are subscribed if you guys want
to see that but if I had to give a
winner as far as you know watching
videos it would have to be the MacBook
Air as far as brightness they are
surprisingly close if you're viewing
them from straight on the MacBook Air
just has a slight lead but they're both
about 350 nits but when you start
shifting off at an angle the galaxy book
asks has a much better job retaining the
brightness you guys could definitely see
that here but the MacBook Air does a
little bit better as far as maintaining
contrast and maybe that's just due to
the brightness going down lower overall
I am more impressed with a galaxy book s
as displayed than I was initially when
they announced the specs for it even
though it's 1080p has good brightness
good contrast and overall it's gonna do
the job for a laptop like
this I think the one area where it's
gonna struggle a little bit is if you're
outdoors trying to watch a movie or
having a darker scene as you guys can
tell by this OLED demo we're getting
much much more reflections with the
galaxy book s than we are with the
MacBook Air and beause these laptops are
maxed out right now with the same angle
and now it's time to compare the
speaker's the MacBook Air has speakers
on the side you guys can see the grills
whereas the galaxy book s doesn't have
anything here but I think the speaker's
there hidden underneath the actual
keyboard here and let's just go ahead
and jump into the comparison and you let
me know which one sounds better down in
the comment section below
[Music]
[Music]
of course you're gonna hear something
that's different than what I'm hearing
because we're recording this it's going
online it depends on what you're
listening to so I'll give you guys my
opinions and I noticed two different
things first off this galaxy book s is
actually louder than the MacBook Air at
least at the start of that song and let
me say that is very very refreshing
because a lot of times the windows
alternatives are much quieter and that
makes it tough if you're in a lot of
environment you're outdoors things like
that so great job Samsung now the second
thing is later on in the song it
actually lowered its volume
automatically and kind of got closer to
the what the MacBook Air does because I
was trying to limit distortion so when
the bass start kicking in the volume
went down now usually I don't like the
kind of modulation of volume
automatically but in this case I think
that's great that can give us more
output for our certain things like
listening a podcast or something else I
will definitely take it now as far as
audio quality the MacBook Air did sound
better to me personally it sound a
little bit more rich especially in the
mids overall I would have to give the
edge to the MacBook Air just because of
the quality of the sound but the Samsung
does doing a great job now it's time to
test the quality of the camera and the
microphone that's built into these
laptops and this is me testing out and
using the Galaxy book s and this is the
webcam and microphone quality with the
MacBook Air go ahead and let me know
which one looks and sounds better down
in the comments section below now
finally let's talk about performance
I have Geekbench v opened up here or
running the CPU test and both of these
processors that are in these laptops are
designed more for power efficiency than
ultimate performance we have a dual-core
eight generation Intel 1.6 gigahertz
processor that will turbo higher and
with the Samsung we have a Snapdragon
processor this is an ARM chip so
designed for mobile like for cell phones
and it has eight cores that can go up to
two point eight four gigahertz so that
is very interesting we have four times
more cores with the Samsung now the same
sense also fanless whereas the MacBook
Air does have a fan but it is a still
silent and most of time you cannot hear
that at all
so the results are in and I'm pretty
surprised now with the single core
performance the MacBook Air does take a
slight lead
whereas with multi-core we have an
almost an extra thousand points with the
galaxy book s and I think that does make
sense because we have a lot more cores
so performance wise overall the galaxy
book s is taking the lead but this
Geekbench 5 score doesn't tell the whole
story because this is an AR M laptop a
lot of programs are not optimized for
that whereas with Mac OS everything is
super well optimized so just going
through web browsers I just noticed that
the MacBook Air is a little bit more
quick whereas the galaxy book s has just
a little bit of lag when you're opening
videos maximizing stuff now it's not as
bad as a surface X that we tested last
year that was really horrible as far as
performance and I think Microsoft has
done some more optimizations some
absolute optimize so I will do a final
kind of performance talk or give you
guys my opinions in the full review of
the galaxy book s so make sure you guys
stay tuned but for now I want to run a
couple tests here the first one's going
to be motion mark which is going to take
tests the graphics for web browsers
because this is an Aeron processor I'm
not able to test it with games or with
Geekbench 5s compute test like I
normally would be able to so
unfortunately the galaxy book keeps
freezing up with these graphics tests
and they're showing up differently so I
shut that off we're gonna have to figure
out another way to test out graphics
with these new ARM chips but for now
let's go ahead and test out the
speedometer web browser test and this is
going to just give us the performance
for the these kind of simple tasks like
web usage and I think a lot of people
are buying one or the other considering
these laptops they're gonna be doing
more basic tasks not like heavy video
editing and things like that and here
are the results we have 38 with the
galaxy book s compared to 77 just over
twice as much with the MacBook Air and
you do feel more snappiness when you're
using the OS opening up different
programs and web browsing with the
MacBook Air than you do with the galaxy
book s and of course do we have
optimizations and certain apps won't
work with this version of Windows 4
chips and that's gonna be a downside
it's gonna take a little longer to get
optimize programs and certain things
running with this new system let's
finish off talking about prices the
galaxy book s starts at 999 dollars
which is a really good price and the
MacBook Air starts at 1200 but that's
only with half the amount of SST and if
we match these up we're looking at a
$400 price difference which is
significant the galaxy book s also comes
with a LTE chip so if you're somebody
that wants to be always connected you
have that capability in that price point
whereas with the MacBook Air you don't
have the option and on the actual iPads
you're gonna pay another $130 or so for
that capability the galaxy book s also
allows you to pop in a microSD card and
expand your storage and that is really
great as well if you want to have extra
storage even though it's gonna be slower
but just a store user from files photos
anything you want on there that can be
done for not a lot of money whereas
upgrading to say a one terabyte option
on here it's gonna cost a lot the other
big selling point with the galaxy book S
is the battery life I've been testing
this for quite a while we ran all those
benchmarks watching videos I was testing
between recording and we're still at 85
percent so it definitely is sipping
power now the MacBook Air doesn't lack
in that area either but the galaxy book
s definitely does better so if you're
somebody that's out on the go you're
traveling you want to be connected with
the LTE you want have excellent battery
life so you don't have to worry about it
at all even for multiple days that is
the strong point of the galaxy book s
now you're gonna be limited as far as
performance but for the people are doing
web browsing email that kind of stuff
you don't need to have a ton of
performance so that's where the galaxy
for custom really shines and the MacBook
Air is just a less expensive alternative
to other mac books if you're looking for
a more typical style of laptop let me
know here guys has thoughts down in the
comment section below which one of these
do you think is worth it and if you want
to see more info about the galaxy book s
I will be testing it out doing multiple
days of tests and real-world usage and
then we will put out our real world
review so make sure you guys subscribe
by clicking that little circle
and enable notifications below and if
you want to see a couple great videos
maybe more real-world tests with the ARM
chip in the surface pro X click right
over there
[Music]